I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
being with us
winning solves everything that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now let's try one more time to explain
stuff to people who I know we're
frustrated and they're confused about
GOP politics right now many Republicans
especially donor types are flummoxed by
recent political polls
now for sure the In Crowd thought that
Trump was finished January 6 and other
impeachment multiple investigations oh a
possible indictment and he's still
relitigating 2020.
but guess what
Trump still has almost a 30-point lead
in the RCP average over Ron DeSantis and
he leads Biden in the head-to-head as
well
but of course this doesn't speak to the
Battleground states that didn't fall
Trump's way less go-round as you
remember in two of those States
according to a new public opinion
strategies poll obtained by McClatchy
DeSantis not Trump narrowly leads Biden
of course DeSantis hasn't jumped into
the race yet he's hinted that he's going
to announce after his State Legislature
wraps its session in May
now this has worried some about this
late timing of desantises which they
claim may leave him ill-prepared to
defend against the former president's
bludgeoning attacks and lagging in the
type of on-the-ground organizing
critical in states with an early
nominating contest
well for his part Trump continues what
to many seem like Petty attacks on
DeSantis and the latest polls about well
the latest about his so-called putting
fingers
and for DeSantis the attack on Trump
wasn't really Petty it was just well
kind of off
now what a gift it would be for Biden if
the election ended up being a referendum
about guns and abortion instead of
Biden's biggest vulnerability which we
all know is the economy
at CVS you gov poll released on Sunday
showed that 97 percent view the economy
as an important issue with inflation at
95 percent Health Care at 94 abortion
was down at 79 percent
so DeSantis is battling Disney Trump is
battling Alvin Bragg crowds are showing
up with some uncomfortable moments for
both men a crowd in Texas didn't seem to
react well recently when Trump during a
rally hit DeSantis pretty hard and
DeSantis seemed a little rattled over
the weekend with a Nutty woman rushed
the stage in New Hampshire
[Music]
[Applause]
gotta have a little Spice in the speech
right I mean you got to have a little
fun
well a few well-known Republicans have
just announced they were supporting
Trump and Thomas pettyfy a
multi-billionaire GOP donor has hit the
pause button on DeSantis citing the
six-week abortion ban just announced now
meanwhile we watch day by day as our
country is slipping away under Biden's
team of fools
we're declining in almost every way and
the White House has no intention of
doing anything to turn it around
in fact decline is their policy now
under these circumstances many are left
wondering how did we get here
now what a lot of Republicans have never
understood is that the Trump movement is
the result of Despair despair among tens
of millions of GOP voters
these folks always knew that the left
was against them and they never trusted
the media but ever since about 2004 or
so they've come to believe that the
leadership of the GOP is also against
them
they see Republicans supporting China
Republicans supporting open borders and
Republicans supporting wasteful silly
Wars
they also see that Republicans with a
few exceptions like Trump and DeSantis
never ever actually defeat the left on
any real issue
the dreaded Larry Hogan Republican in
name only of Maryland was governor there
of course is Maryland more conservative
as a result of Hogan's tenure
now clearly Governor Hogan would rather
have Biden reelected than Trump or
anyone who agrees with Trump on any
policy or rather have Biden win the
presidency
successful politics is about addition
and multiplication it's not about
subtraction and division we haven't
focused on the things that the average
American cares about and it's what you
know the my entire efforts have been
about people that's what's so
confounding for people that you're not
running I felt like I was in a Lifeboat
by myself and it was the SS Titanic
Trump was was going by more and more
people are jumping off the boat we now
need a bigger boat
okay that made no sense Charlie Baker
another so-called Republican was
governor of Massachusetts well did he
really move that state to the right
we need as a party to move past
uh president Trump and to move on to an
agenda that represents the voices of all
those
in the party and the people of the
country I've just chosen to make
the way I govern and the way we get
things done
a statement about how I think this
should work it's so sanctimonious isn't
he well the way I govern well the result
of the way he governs after Baker
Massachusetts voters turned the
governorship over to Liberal Democrat
Maura Healey
and that's what happens when
establishment Republicans win they end
up presiding over slow liberal
entrenchment
so if their brand of conservatism is so
in touch with the people why didn't John
McCain or Mitt Romney win in New England
states in 2008 and 2012. they didn't
and if so-called moderate conservatives
have what it takes
why don't they thrive in places like
California where there are plenty of
wealthy people
and one would think that the supposed
brainiacs and the old GOP guard would
have straightened out the Pentagon
straightened out the Intel Community
right
wrong
both institutions these days they're
just as woke as Academia
after watching all these developments
most Republican voters who are populous
whether or not they identify that way
they've come to conclude that the GOP as
a National Institution is effectively
useless
now state gops may be effective in
places like Alabama or Florida but the
national GOP it's not going to stop
China it's not going to push the
Republicans to enforce the borders it's
not going to reform the Pentagon it's
not going to lower the debt it just
won't
in fact it was the acceptable wing of
the GOP that gave Biden one of his
biggest crowning achievements that
boondoggle infrastructure Bill Mitch uh
it's uh you know
it wasn't easy it wouldn't have happened
without your hand I just wouldn't have
gotten done and I want to thank you for
that
now its passage is what made possible on
a simple majority vote the even worse
so-called inflation reduction Act
so we had trillions of dollars blown
which further drove up inflation and
gave Biden wide regulatory authority to
move against gas-powered cars which he
did last week
that EPA is proposing the strongest ever
Federal pollution technology standards
for both cars and trucks today's actions
will accelerate our ongoing transition
to a clean vehicles future
voters see this and they think thanks
Mitch
and once you've concluded that the
national GOP doesn't work well you may
as well support Trump
well maybe it's just a protest vote
anyway right
so if the GOP wants to change this
Dynamic I'm not saying they should but
if they want to change this dynamic they
need to start winning
they need to start seeing articles on
the national media about how Biden got
played by McConnell
not the other way around
we need to see progressives complaining
that their guys are rolling over for
Republicans instead of the other way
around
and most of all we need to see that the
GOP has both the will and the ability to
defeat the political forces undermining
America at home and abroad
winning fixes everything
Reagan won a bunch of battles in the
1980s and the bushes were still running
on those victories in the 2000s
if the GOP starts winning again most of
its problems are going to go away
if the folks who run the GOP really want
to beat Trump and nominate someone else
they need to show that they can beat the
Democrats and so far no good and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else